now we're going to wait till 17 seconds
so when we see the next one we should
have two back to back 17 and 18.
there it is there it is look at that you
guys i'm telling you man
ladies and gentlemen welcome
to retro rackets who are live my friends
thank you so much for being here tonight
all right there we go i love you
oh my oh my who sent that
who sent that i think it's the name of
the song actually
yeah it is i was like what is that
exactly
log dining table i think my son already
has this but i'm gonna drop it outside
his house here just in case he doesn't
yeah we got the pirate shield ship helm
this is pretty cool looking
i'm definitely gonna be able to use that
for some decoration somewhere
definitely gonna use that for decoration
all right i think i got everything done
there that i need to i need to put it
feels so weird when i walk in any room
without music
see there we go i just i gotta have
music when i'm in the rooms
[Music]
alright so we can go and we've got a few
minutes
so again i can't let the time slip up on
me here because
uh the shooting star should be arriving
at 9 54
guys do not let me forget
9 54. so here's what i'm going to do i'm
going to run outside i'm going to go
over to
nook's cranny sell everything but the
fish because cj's going to be in town
tomorrow for the
tourney which should be for all of you
by the way all
northern hemisphere islands you will see
cj tomorrow okay
let's go we still got plenty time before
we're 10. you know what before i forget
i should just go ahead and
set an alarm that's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna set an alarm on my phone
it just says shooting stars
all right here we go so uh
my son and i were doing this a few weeks
ago we had we had our
it's the first time we got our weather
actually figured out
uh all right so i set it for 9 53 p.m
and then we'll have exactly one minute
to get into position but as long as
you're outside
you can hear them and look up you're
fine oh that looks pretty cool
i'm surprised my wife doesn't want that
maybe i should buy it for you guys
yes you look at my look at my sad sad
turnip prices here
59 bells i had a decreasing pattern it
was going down
every single day
so we'll definitely check in with him
here if he's still here i can't remember
what time gulliver leaves but
hello techs what's up dude
all right so let's head down and see
what octavian's up to octavian our
latest
villager to move in guys if you were
tuned into the last stream then you saw
me do my first ever
villager hunt which went way better oh
this is not his house it's broccolo what
am i doing here
broccolo what's up dude you couldn't
find me yeah dude i haven't been in my
house all day
broccoli you are a strange dude let me
tell you
look at him have it sipping his coffee
here at the late hours of
10 p.m just about at night
man yeah that's right this one right
here
this is octavian's house and he is in he
is in right now let's see what
octavian's up to
maybe we can get a recipe from him how
great would that be get a recipe from
him on his first
wow octavian oh my
what is this spaceship beaming the alien
up
the night is young let's act like it hey
this is my kind of dude right here
octavian i am so glad we got you on the
island can't wait for the fishing
tourney to start tomorrow
got your fishing rod ready been
practicing my cast every chance i get
not to to my own horn but i should warn
you i'm something of a fishing expert
oh boy i mean you are an aquatic
animal all right don't let my score
throw you for a loop tomorrow kiddo
dude yes this house is amazing
i didn't even know this was an item
right here
wow and they're all this is like
actually floating look at this
the dude doesn't sleep i guess he just
like goes to a corner and chills
although he said he's a night owl you
know so maybe he uh
maybe sleeps during the day the night is
young
all right let me run i think i've got
just enough time before the first wave
of shooting stars
just enough time to run to my house and
drop some of these items off
and then if you guys have no idea what
i'm talking about when i'm talking about
predicting your weather
there is an online a free online website
if you just go to google and search for
medio nook m-e-t-e-o
nook in oh okay just like tom nook
it will lead you to it the guy who does
a lot of data
mining for animal crossing built this
tool
and i've got a full video on my youtube
page that shows you exactly how to do it
because i'm not going to lie to you guys
it is complicated to to figure out your
weather pattern
once you figure out the weather pattern
though it's incredible how well it works
it's incredible it's you can
predict your weather for every hour
which includes shooting stars that's why
i keep saying
hey i've got shooting stars here at this
time
because you can pinpoint them to the
exact second
all right 9 52 this alarm's going to go
off at 9 53 we'll just go on and get
ready
i need to go down to the beach anyway
that's my that's my favorite place to
look for the shooting stars
is because i just go out to the pier and
you get a nice
clear view here
[Music]
all right right here's where we're gonna
hang out
okay so at 9
54. right now for my time and i don't
know how much of a delay it is
you guys will see on the stream but my
time it's 9 53
eastern time at 9 54 and then
in three seconds so it hit 954 and then
we'll say
one two three i'll get a shooting star
then it's 17 18 28
and 34. i want you guys to watch
i'm setting all this up it's probably
gonna fail terribly
but i want you guys to watch how
accurate this thing is i already did it
once and it was
it was like accurate to the exact second
so we'll see if it works again this time
if not i'll just be staring up at the
sky with nothing at all happening
okay 954 there it is that was three
seconds
that was the first one now we're gonna
wait till 17 seconds
so when we see the next one we should
have two back to back 17 and 18.
there it is there it is look at that you
guys i'm telling you man
and then 10 seconds later so at 28 we'll
have another one
and then at 34 all right there it is
and then shouldn't be too long for this
one six seconds
there it is and so there
is my wave of five shooting stars unreal
right
unreal man
but the hard part is getting to this
point getting to this point where i'm at
where you can do this
there are over two billion
possible weather seeds so there are more
potential weather seats for this game
than copies that will ever sell
of this game which is mind-blowing right
so now that we had that one we're gonna
have another meteor shower
at uh 10 19 so we don't have too long to
wait for that one so i'm going to adjust
the alarm in my phone here
i'll make one for 10 18.
all right 10 18 so then we'll be ready
and this is a light shower so with the
light showers they just don't
they just don't come like they do like
when i was at your hou uh your island
piggy
you had the heavy meteor shower is it me
or have folks been calling you cruiser
lately
how'd you notice handling that's cool it
sounds like a special
special move is that all right if i call
you cruiser too
i mean
don't do that
oh flag on the play and i can't do
anything about it
guess we'll just forget it then hammy
yeah i mean i i
the nicknames wait what did i just
unlock for that
oh just talking to a villager for
turning him down i
i earned a nook miles point or something
all right so
fishing tourney tomorrow let's go ahead
and just kind of make our way up the
beach here
uh and we can kind of kill two birds of
one stone in addition to
getting these little guys right here we
can also be checking our palm trees
because we are still looking for a
couple of the new bugs
the horned elephant the golden stag
and giraffe stag we still need all three
of those
man that's thing i love about manila
clams you do not have to look hard for
them
they just they're just like hey we're
here we're hanging out
we're hanging out and we're here to stay
you never have to worry about looking
too hard for them
yeah i might as well go ahead and get
the fossils tonight too
haven't gotten those in a few days uh we
also have uh i think my son told me we
have a new
lily of the valley plant that those are
the plants that grow whenever you
whenever your island hits five stars
and so i need to go and move it because
i have a specific section where i'm
putting all of those yes gulver is still
here let's go
all right we got to wake him up guys not
gullivar
just regular gulliver here although i'm
kind of glad because i need to uh
i need to get a lot of rusted parts my
son and i still want to craft the big
robot
that was one of the very first recipes
we ever bought
and rusted parts apparently one of the
hardest items in the game to find
because you
you only get one when you do
gulliver's little uh
challenge for the week and i think what
a lot of people have done is like traded
and stuff
and then of course you have a bunch of
people out there time travel
kind of speed things up i think those
are the only people who have been able
to finish it yet
because gulliver just he's not even
guaranteed to show up each week as far
as i know
now they did recently change up the
spawn rates a bit so he might be
guaranteed now i've got him on
back-to-back days i got gullivar
yesterday and then regular gulliver
today
yeah your communicators busted we know
we know
we know they're buried in the sand i'll
take care of it go over you know i got
you
you know i got you five parts okay
for any of you who have uh seen gullivar
go ahead and let me know which one you
like the best
uh which one you like the best in terms
of their aesthetic and then also
which challenge you like better because
when you get go avar you have to go out
into the ocean
and dive where there are bubbles and you
only have to find it one time once you
find it
you actually pull up the communicator a
little looks like a little cell phone
whereas when you get the gulliver and
you have to find the
parts on land you have to find five of
them
so i'm curious as to how people uh what
people think about that
if you like it better just finding one
out on the
ocean or if you'd rather
just stay on land and find the five
parts
so right now we've got to find four
because we already found the first one
there hey hermit crab
all right let's go and head out over
this side i always need to walk slow
right here because i have that palm tree
i want to make sure i don't miss
anything
that might be on it oh there we go right
here
all right it's number two for the rusted
part or
communicator part i call them rustic
parts
my fault look at this this is just like
such a nice area
my sons had this one who had the idea to
put the fan out there like hey that's
it's a pretty good idea you know on the
beach you don't usually have to worry
about uh having a breeze you almost
always have one there
so but i still thought it was a good
idea he's like that'll keep you cool
while you're
sitting on the beach
all right it's number three and we got
our bottle here so for our recipe of the
day
so just in terms of uh whenever i play
at night kind of the
nightly routine that i like to go
through classic library wall
let's go i usually like to check and see
if i have any visitors so
if wisp is there if celeste is there uh
like right now gold are still hanging
out if i haven't done already done it
during the day
clear up my inventory make sure anything
that i need to put in my house from the
previous day that i go ahead and
and put it away stored away
sometimes i'll sell items in the little
item box
but i mean at this point in the game
i've already got my house fully upgraded
so money's not a huge deal
if you're earlier in the game though you
probably want to save your items for the
next day
because you're going to get more for
them selling when nook's cranny is
open than you would if you drop them in
the box so
and the other thing is i just try and
pick up any weeds any rocks like this
any wood that's fallen to the ground
we're probably gonna have a lot of wood
up there by the campsite
here's the little lily of the valley
area i mentioned so
i'll be able to bring another one down
or did my son already he may have
already brought it down because i don't
think
i think we needed one on this side to
even it up but maybe i'm wrong
i'll double check here in a bit we'll
look around up on the cliffs and see if
we can find any uh right now we need
what two more communication parts
oh there's a uh horned dynastid
i need to upgrade this net to
keep forgetting that i have it on flimsy
until i need it of course and then i'm
like oh yeah that's on a flimsy net
i have a little uh
crafting area up here though that i can
use to
i think i got rid of all my i did i got
rid of all my
iron nuggets though
all right come on don't make me walk
what
come on give it to me there we go oh
it's just
it's middle clam i feel like it's super
rare to see a manila clam once you get
the mission from gulliver
you almost always get rusted parts with
just
one or two manila clams sprinkled in
there all right so we walked all the way
down
i think we have three of them oh we
got five what is wrong with my counting
you guys
holy crap sorry about that i'm just like
no wonder i'm getting manila clams now
all right so we need to head back to
gulliver finish that up
and then we can go look for the
for the lily of the valley let's catch
this dude right here though
uh the atlas moth
they're worth quite a bit and it's
already after 10 so no point in
heading back to nooks or trying to get
back there quickly
that guy i did not see until it was too
late
i already had him but still
all right we'll go ahead and keep keep
gathering these along the way
because we're gonna need them for the
fishing tourney tomorrow
man everybody dominated that first
fishing tourney
and i was not prepared i i didn't do any
research so i didn't know
like kind of the ways to to get a really
good score
looks like a little weed is just hiding
behind here
the other thing i like to do at night is
just go around and try to make sure all
my flowers are
where i need them to be and some that
have overgrown i'll go ahead and remove
those
yo huck pulling a wardrobe change right
there
and my island rains so much i feel like
i constantly have to move flowers
because they sprout a new
oh celeste is here dude let's go
[Music]
have a splendid rest of the night i know
i shall thank you celeste very much very
good to see you
mom's wand what
like the flower mums
that's hilarious my wife's been wanting
us to make her
a wand so off to see what kind she wants
she'll probably want the star wand
let me show you all the ones i got oh
she might want the shell the shell one's
nice
what do they show up under though i know
i have more than that
let's see are they cool i guess okay
they're considered tools all right
yeah we got the bunny day wand
the shell wand the bamboo one the star
wand and then we just
unlocked mum's wand right there
mum's wand though just hearing that i
don't think of the flower i just think
of like your like mom's one
mom's wand
all right celeste thank you for hooking
us up
there's a saw stag right there because
of this little hammock right here it is
a challenge to catch this bug
we got it under control though it's all
good i caught a miami stag it's
mandibles are jaw-dropping
but um dude i keep forgetting i've gotta
go
that's the thing about animal crossing
man people say there's not a lot to do
and i i get it but you get in here and
you have your routine
it is so easy to get sidetracked into
like oh there's this oh there's that oh
yeah i need to do this
okay so our time is uh at 10 19
and then once it hits 10 19 we're gonna
we're gonna wait for the 20-second mark
so at the 22nd mark we'll get
uh one then we'll get another one at 21
39 55 58.
so if you guys are just jumping into the
stream we have uh
found our weather seed using the medio
nook
tool it's free you can get to it online
and as part of that tool you have the
ability to
know exactly when your shooting stars
will be
and so there it is 1019 all right so 20
seconds gonna take a little bit for this
one
this is my favorite spot out on the dock
no obstructions at all
just the peaceful peaceful sound of the
waves there's one
there they go back to back 10 and 11
just as
predicted guys i'm sorry 20 and 21 were
the times
next one will be at 39.
there we go and then the last two 55 and
58.
there it is and one two three
there's the last one all right so the
next one is not
until 10 58
so let me go into my alarm and set the
one for 10.58
we'll probably still be streaming at
that point
let me do 10 58 p.m
uh yes so i did it for 10 58 10 59 is
when
the shooting stars will show up
can we do that this stream wait what do
you mean smash bros
nah for smash bros i i want it to be
we'll have a big return for smash bros
because p smash bros used to be our
main that was like our go-to game a lot
of the people
who visit this stream regularly found us
through
through playing smash so i want to have
i want to have a full night
set aside and dedicated to play smash i
will be
so rusty at this point it will not be
pretty
it will not be pretty at all you could
probably find some of the old smash
streams back in the if you go through my
vod like on twitch they
they save your videos but they they go
away after a while so
it's been it's been a couple months
since i played smash at all
i got so annoyed by the wi-fi the the
online in that game is
it's just a terrible netcode
yeah we had an attorney about a year
well a little over a year ago we did a
smash bros tourney
had a had a giveaway with with money and
everything
i think i gave away 25 to the winner
and then 25 to a random follower we did
a big uh
sticker pack giveaway yeah i would uh i
would definitely be interested in doing
another attorney at some point the why
though again the internet was just so
bad
and now since this whole quarantine
thing i've seen more and more people
of the top pros in smash complaining
about that
boy mom welcome back how's it going boy
mom we got shooting stars
on the island tonight also gulliver over
here and
we're collecting clams getting ready for
the uh fishing tourney tomorrow
although piggy power8 here just told us
about
a website called nuke azan
i guess it's like a amazon for or
amazon for animal crossing i guess is
what you would how you describe it i
haven't used it but i'm definitely going
to check it out
apparently people are paying 1 million
bells for stacks of
of the fish bait which is mind-blowing
to me
beedelphon is here and watching now as
well i'll beat up welcome to the stream
the del pont sporting that first badge
one of the
very first subs of the stream along with
chris stallion who was here a little bit
earlier
that's them those are definitely the
communicator parts nice
but what i do need to do i almost missed
that little extra flower right there
see so this is just part of like the the
relaxing nighttime routine just going
around
clearing up all the little things on
your island now i know for sure this
area up here
yeah it's gonna have a lot of stuff that
we need to
because i just haven't been here in a
while
dude this is crazy
you're both in central time you're both
expecting almost the same exact time
next thing you know we're gonna figure
out you guys like know each other in
real life and didn't even realize
oh man that's crazy dude small world
small world
so yeah be del pont guys uh for the
regulars of the stream they know that's
my sister
we gotta work on getting her a different
twitch name
b del pont just doesn't roll off the
tongue you know she said she laughs
every time i say it
[Music]
it's like well i don't want to just give
out your personal name
online i don't think most people would
care but you know
i mean some people crazy out there y'all
so but yeah she's my sister and she
and i developed a love for animal
crossing
uh from the first game on the gamecube
and so she doesn't have a switch she
said she's not buying it just for one
game
so what she does instead is she just
watches my stream so she like
she plays animal crossing through me i
guess you could say
so yeah this area up here the campsite
we've got a lot of these little
wooden sticks we need to pick up here
and then i think i need to be on the
lookout for that
lily of the valley plant although he may
have already moved it
ah i rushed that one
end of august for you okay so first part
of september
end of august okay so about a month
separating the two
where did he say that that lily of the
valley plant was
oh almost missed it this little wood
right here just hiding behind that tree
ah he went early that is possible
my wife was like right on time for both
of them it's kind of crazy
i mean i guess that's the norm there's a
reason it's the due date
but i just still i feel i still feel
like most people that
i hear oh i went earlier oh i went way
late
all right guys i think he had to move
that lily of the valley plant my son did
already
so let me do another quick double check
this area all these are money trees by
the way right here
i've got to figure out what i want to do
with this
i am thinking about completely
demolishing the island at some point
you guys just so you all know
we got to keep the content flowing for
animal crossing and i feel like i'm
going to hit a point here pretty soon
where
we need to make some big changes here's
the idea i've got in my head
this would take a lot to pull off
just check wednesday's stream did i have
one missing on the right a lily of the
valley
plant
he did already move it then okay good
for him
i told him i would move it he's probably
like dad i'm tired of waiting for you
i'm tired of waiting so he went ahead
and uh moved it
when i looked let me show you guys the
area
when i looked earlier i was like i don't
remember this being even
the last time i checked it i remembered
me still
lacking one right here so i bet he dug
that one up
and replaced it good for him
give him a little pat on the back
tomorrow for that
all right let's go and get this flower
out of the way but yeah i'm thinking
about here's what i'm thinking about
doing
i'm thinking about this would take a lot
to pull off but i've seen
some of my favorite islands that i've
seen on youtube and other twitch
streamers
are the islands that have like
themed areas for
each villager well maybe not each
villager but like
like on my island huck and hamlet
they're the jocks so they're always
talking about lifting weights
so have them in an area with like a
basketball court
or a baseball field and we have weights
and stuff like that
around them then for
uh octavian the newcomer have like a
pirate themed area or something
uh let's swap it i'm gonna swap it with
let this black bass go
seal that and then we'll go check in at
the museum
looks like we still got a few more
flowers to remove over here
we still also need to get the tiger
prawn and the vampire squid
oh how dare you my outdoorsy shovel
no let's see did i finish though i think
i did
i think i did all right so i don't need
to worry about crafting one immediately
go ahead and water these right here
still trying to get a couple more gold
roses
i should really move these and get rid
of the red rose there but
since the shovel just broke i'm not
gonna do it right now
look at text just walking around
enjoying the flowers
let's see did i get this one yet
got that one and i did that one
pretty sure
although i don't trust myself forget
pretty sure we're making sure
oh i do have to make another shovel
anyway because
all right let's see i've got a crafting
table up here
maybe i put them i didn't go back in my
house though did i
i was gonna say maybe i put them in my
house
might as well craft the one we've got
and then we need to make a new shovel
trouble shovel shovel don't have what we
need
all right hardwood i've got that in my
house so
all right we watered all those
what is that oh is that the i think
that's the cyclo mattis
we already have him but i'll catch him
again
oh my goodness crystallion
wow i gotta check that out
oh the horn atlas let's go there are so
many like the cree the possibilities of
creativity
in animal crossing it's kind of insane
what people come up with i would i would
love to do a harry potter one but
hold on i've already seen a ton of
people doing that
great white
out for its jaws
okay so where are we at we got a couple
of fossils
might as well go ahead and have those
assessed
what would be really cool with that box
is if you could go back into it
and get items that you've sold out since
technically
they haven't had a pickup yet you know
they haven't picked it up
they're not gonna pick it up till
morning how great would that be if you'd
be like whoops didn't mean to sell that
and just take it back out ladies and
gentlemen it's been a great stream
tonight i hope you guys had as much fun
as i
have chatting with you guys playing some
animal crossing
new horizons
[Music]
uh if you do the fishing tourney good
luck in the fishing tourney tomorrow i
hope you catch and get all the rewards
you want
and i'll talk to you again soon guys
later